il sera stationné à chaque fois à
proximité directe des salles des fêtes
levac cybus fait étape ce jour-là à
maule mise en place par le département
des yvelines est l' agence régionale de
santé il servira à acheminer des doses
files heures elles sont à destination
des personnes de plus de 75 ans vivant
dans les communes rurales
les vaccins sont stockés dans le
véhicule préparé avant d'être administré
à l'intérieur des salles des fêtes par
une équipe médicale
un dispositif complémentaire au centre
de vaccination des gens en place
levac six bus permet d'aller sur des
communes qui sont pas forcément
aujourd'hui couverte par un centre de
vaccination est d'aller au devant de la
population qui a des difficultés pour
accéder à une vaccination dans ces
centres de vaccination pour aller au
contact de nos concitoyens qui ne
peuvent pas forcément se déplacer
facilement en particulier donc les
personnes âgées parce que ça n'est pas
très simple pour elle de se rendre dans
des lieux de vaccination éloignés
levac six bus se rendra dans les
intercommunalités de gally mauldre de
coeur divine et des portes
d'ile-de-france 120 doses seront
administrés à chaque journée de
vaccination elles profiteront villages
des alentours l'opération à maule ce
vendredi 5 mars était adressée également
aux habitants de cinq autres communes
ces personnes ont été identifiées
directement par les municipalités
quand on en arrive en âge surtout comme
moi qui n'a absolument plus aucun parent
aucun ami aucun enfant je suis contente
d'avoir de pouvoir être soigné symbole
je pense que ce démarrage la plus le
centre de crespières qui se met en place
la semaine prochaine
je crois que ça va ça va rassurer
beaucoup de monde au delà du taxibus
neuf centres de vaccination sont en
place dans le département quatre sites
supplémentaires doivent ouvrir dans la
semaine du 8 mars